good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i'm will kane in for
tucker
disturbing phone calls started coming
into jacksonville sheriff's police
office on a wednesday night just a few
weeks ago motorists had reported seeing
a man covered in blood walking along the
highway and then he disappeared into the
woods when authorities finally arrested
the man the next morning they identified
him as a honduran migrant named medina
aloa now aloa claimed to be a teenager
authorities followed the trail of blood
left by medina oloa to find his victim a
46 year old father of four
and security cameras showed lois
stabbing the man multiple times and
beating him to death with a chair in his
own home just a terrible story now
investigators suspect aloha was lying
about his identity so they checked in
with the honduran consulate and that's
when they found out that medina aloha is
not in fact a teenager
he's actually 23 years old and he's in
this country illegally so how did he get
here
it turns out aloha did not sneak across
the border he didn't overstay his visa
no
instead according to a report in the new
york post aloha crossed the border under
a fake name pretending to be an
unaccompanied minor
and in keeping with the biden
administration's immigration policies he
was led into the country he was placed
into a shelter and then he was released
the biden administration then reportedly
put aloha on a secret resettlement
flight to florida
the governor of florida ron desantis has
called this what it is it's a deliberate
effort by the biden administration to
endanger american citizens in exchange
for political power
this individual has been detained should
have never been in this country to begin
with and definitely should not have been
dumped in the state of florida and so
these are middle of the night flights no
no notification to the state or anybody
and this is not the way
you keep people safe
no it's not
the body administration isn't just
letting record number of illegal
immigrants cross our borders they're
bringing them here
and they're prohibiting immigration
authorities from deporting any of them
even
ones with violent criminal records to be
clear
this is against the law section 236 c of
the immigration and nationality act
requires ice to arrest and hold almost
all
removable criminal aliens congress
passed that law
and joe biden is simply ignoring it the
same way he ignores pesky questions at a
press conference by turning his back and
shuffling away he's shuffling away
from this problem now that's why the
state of texas is currently suing the
biden administration they want the law
enforced and as part of that lawsuit
we're starting to learn much more about
the kind of people the biden
administration is allowing to stay in
this country
jason clark he's the chief of staff of
the texas department of criminal justice
he said in an affidavit attained by this
show
that ice has rescinded detainers for at
least 130 illegal immigrants between
january 20th and october 20th so what
does that mean rescinding detainers that
means ice no longer wants to take
custody of these illegal immigrants when
they are released in order to deport
them i shows no interest is following
their orders not to deport these
criminals
now look to give you just an idea of how
unprecedented this is
no detainers
zero were rescinded in this same time
period one year ago
these aren't just minor criminals we're
talking about that ice is refusing to
deport
clark's affidavit states that one of the
illegal immigrants allowed to stay in
this country
is a man named rolando camacho and he
was convicted of intoxicated
manslaughter with a vehicle
another example charles mainza he was in
prison for theft of property worth more
than twenty five hundred dollars he was
released from texas custody in february
ice
never arrested him they dropped his
detainer
luis ola rodriguez was released from a
texas prison in september he was there
for having multiple dwis
and eulessa espinoza had her detainer
dropped by ice in march she was locked
up for credit card abuse and when police
arrested her they found her with card
numbers that matched 15 different food
stamp cards
but nothing nothing tops 24 year old
jose reyes
reyes was arrested by ice in 2018
he was later released from ice custody
and in less than a year after that reyes
was convicted of drunk driving he was
again released
and then he decided to become a poet
he spoke at an open border protest that
attacked ice for enforcing federal
immigration laws
dear america our administration has
failed
they passed loss against our people took
away our rights and our freedom and
still expect to be held
child is dear america
you and your administration cause fear
fear through separation instead of
building trust with our people do y'all
prefer his racial attention
oppressed
i live my life in frustration
private prisons political funding mass
incarceration you make the connection
it's time to begin standing up for
what's right criminalizing children
separating families our national
security does this make it all right
beautiful you can tell by the music
less than 48 hours after he read that
very moving poem
reyes was arrested again by ice
most of the media treated it like an
outrage in fact two nfl athletes
washington redskins cornerback josh
norman and new orleans saints linebacker
demario davis helped pay for reyes's
bail
now
tonight
reyes is on the run again but this time
for allegedly murdering a 58-year-old
man and throwing his body in an orchard
i wonder is there a poem for that
the body administration's so-called
build back better act would help a lot
more people like jose reyes get out of
jail it would require dhs to grant
parole to virtually every illegal alien
who's lived in this country for the past
decade and that means they can stay here
without any fear of deportation
the democrats bill would allow illegal
immigrants with dui convictions and even
gang members to qualify for parole
and you by the way would be paying for
this amnesty 2.8 billion dollars is
allocated in the bill to process
applications for amnesty as quote
efficiently as possible in other words
the white house isn't upset that people
like jose reyes or medina lower are
getting out of jail they're upset
that it's taking them so long to be
sprung on the public hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else